بيان صادر عن القوات المسلحه اليمنيه بسم
الله الرحمن الرحيم قال تعالى يا ايها
الذين امنوا ان تنصروا الله ينصركم ويثبت
اقدامكم صدق الله العظيم انتصارا لمظلوم
الشعب الفلسطيني وضمن الرد على العدوان
الامريكي البريطاني على بلدنا نفذت القوات
البحريه في القوات المسلحه اليمنيه وبعون
الله تعالى عمليه استهداف لسفينه نفطيه
بريطانيه مارلين لواندا في خليج عدن بعدد
من الصواريخ البحريه المناسبه وكانت
الاصابه مباشره ما ادى الى احتراقها بفضل
الله ان القوات المسلحه اليمنيه تؤكد
استمرار عملياتها في البحرين الاحمر
والعربي ضد السفن الاسرائيليه او المتجهه
الى فلسطين المحتله حتى وقف العدوان
وادخال الغذاء والدواء الى الشعب
الفلسطيني المحاصر في قطاع غزه تؤكد
القوات المسلحه اليمنيه اتخاذها كافه
الاجراءات العسكريه ضمن حق الدفاع عن
اليمن العزيز وتاكيدا على استمرار التضامن
العملي مع الشعب الفلسطيني والله حسبنا
ونعم الوكيل نعم المولى ونعم النصير عاش
اليمن حرا عزيزا مستقلا والنصر لليمن ولكل
احرار الامه صنعاء ال من رجب
1445 للهجره الموافق لل 26 من يناير
2024 صادر عن القوات المسلحه
اليمنيه